over 80% of the world's energy needs are
provided by coal oil and gas
although technologies to extract fossil
fuels may have changed over the decades
the core products themselves have never
been challenged until now a lot of
people question whether large dinosaur
of an oil and gas company can really
compete in such a new high-tech
environment pressure to reduce carbon
emissions is putting the future of
fossil fuels in jeopardy
encouraging the growth of alternative
methods to generate and distribute power
we are not just dairy farmer here we are
energy farmers as well every private
person can produce his own energy in
just eight years the value of the
world's biggest power companies has
halved leaving industry Giants
scrambling to redefine their role in
this new energy world when I started my
career we were a monopoly it's always
technology that truly disrupts Singh's
across the world old industries are
facing disruption on an unprecedented
scale people are not making our taxes
the pressure to adapt has never been
greater it is always survival of the
fittest that's capitalism because were
there's threat there's also opportunity
December 2015 the Paris climate
conference
for the first time ever 195 countries
agreed to a legally binding climate deal
to reduce carbon emissions I think
everyone in the oil and gas industry
agrees that it's going to be a different
future this five trillion dollar
industry may be facing a seismic shift
but that doesn't mean it's ready to
ditch the dirty fossil fuels that made
it rich
instead many companies are banking on
new methods to clean up an old process
Norwegian oil and gas giant Statoil
struck it rich in the North Sea in the
late 1960s over four decades later at
its Lightner gas rig the company is
attempting to make fossil fuel
production cleaner we have an ambition
to become the most carbon efficient oil
and gas producer in the world the world
will look for companies like ourselves
that take a proactive stand on this and
deliver oil and gas to the world but
doing it in a sustainable manner stat
oils business still relies on the
harmful burning of fossil fuels by its
customers but at least the company is
trying to reduce its own carbon
footprints it's transformed some of its
offshore rigs with technology that
enables engineers to separate the carbon
dioxide and pump it underground
Statoil slightly gas rig is the world's
first offshore carbon capture storage
plant
a slave now we have a lot of co2 in our
gas so we need to capture that strip it
out of the gas stream before we can
export the gas in here you will have
continuous stream of captured co2 going
down through this well into the
subsurface about 1,000 meters below us
and then we store this or two in the
subsurface for ever and ever
each year Statoil stores 1 million tons
of co2 making extraction less
carbon-intensive they believe that
prioritizing gas over more harmful
fossil fuels will further reduce global
warming and keep them relevant for
decades to come
one of the advantages of the gas is that
it's very abundant it's very reliable
and it's very flexible you can turn the
gas stream on and off so you can
regulate your gas flow very very easily
gas may be reliable but fossil fuels
will always mean carbon emissions wind
and solar are cleaner but depend on
subsidies to take on the consistency of
fossil fuels they face a huge challenge
the unpredictable weather
in Bavaria a tiny village has used those
subsidies to take up the challenge this
community believes it's found a way to
produce a steady energy supply just from
renewable sources raising the real
prospects of a future free from fossil
fuels we have not just Dairy Milk we
have as well
energy farming and here you can see a
part of our solar panels we have several
points where we catch the Sun and make
energy Norbert and Christina Beck Telus
family farm has been providing the local
community with dairy products for over
200 years but they now have a new income
from solar energy
Invicta catalyst mid-level un3
photovoltaic and lager their strong din
we often Dacian product Ian un7 Ebro
convert indirect own for broad producing
your own energy with solar panels isn't
revolutionary but in this village
they're combining solar with other
renewables in an attempt to achieve the
holy grail of a steady energy supply
and they're prepared to use anything to
do it the cows always produce my New
York deputy mayor Gunther moogle a has
helped drive the villages pioneering
efforts to make renewable energy a
realistic option we can prove that we
always have more than 100 percent of
energy even if there is no wind and no
sound at all
there's one renewable that never
disappears as it can be sourced from the
decay of virtually any organic matter
it's called biogas
of the for biogas plants in the village
farmer ein Seidler runs the largest
people on wicked coffee three blocks
really happy to say I was some yeah you
got some of the boxes are showing we're
from Boston
finita and so she's the news
combining these different sources has
been so successful the village now
generates five times more energy than it
needs but that's just part of the
challenge of turning renewables into a
credible energy supply it's not only
about renewable energy generation it's
also about power saving and energy
saving in order to be able to use wind
and solar power literally around the
clock
storage is absolutely key within this
community one young company has
developed a home battery system that
enables the villages to store the excess
solar energy they produce for later use
we are the first to offer storage
systems for the residential market in
the world and obviously storage helps
customers to use solar power regardless
with the sun shining or not the
technology behind this battery system
also holds the key to a much bigger
prize for the villages supplying energy
to each other
our battery systems are online and we
can recognize in real-time
who is currently feeding power into the
grid and who still needs power from the
grid and an amazing result is that you
have both customers who have excess
power and customers who need power from
the grid and our general idea was let
them share their power between each
other and to get rid of stinky coal
plants and nuclear power stations our
customers can literally replace the
traditional utility is 100% and go
independent
Norbert and Christina supply 50
neighboring households with the energy
they generate for the outside is sister
suna does he our Christine would a
strong product yet but on snitched from
gross in concern or light and fan
confirming its own Martin mousse
where this community has led many others
have now followed there are now almost
1000 energy cooperatives around Germany
it's a major challenge for the country's
big four utilities in eight years the
biggest Eon has seen its share price
fall by over three quarters when I
started my career we were a monopoly
technology has tremendously changed
renewables are getting cheaper and
cheaper customer behaviour is changing
tremendously and society with climate
change and other issues has total
different expectations to the industry
so the industry was shaken up at its
fundament and it's a total different
industries from the 27 years ago when I
started
Ian's income from fossil fuels has
fallen by more than a third since 2008
the company recently made a drastic
decision to fully commit to the
Renewable revolution
Aeon has taken a very brave step we
broke the company I would say into all
the commodity business is the
traditional fossil power plants all
those businesses we spin off into a
company called Unipro and we are
remaining with renewables Eon plans to
spin-off the majority share of its
fossil fuel assets by the end of 2016
and scale up its investment in wind and
solar
but rather than focus on just generating
renewable power Eon is sensing its real
opportunity lies in managing this
diverse new supply on an industrial
scale this green society needs to be
managed here you need to manage millions
of feeding and consumption sites you
will have sharing economies in between
you will have under overconsumption at
time this management equation big data
mining technical competence is obviously
something this world needs and Eon will
strive for being a capable partner in
that to secure its place in this new
decentralized energy world this former
monopoly is taking steps that would have
been unthinkable just a decade ago we
are open for any kind of partnerships
with any partner with any customer and
yes this is also a new attitude we don't
need to control the world
Theon's partnerships have produced a
raft of renewable energy projects at the
Arcona wind farm in the Baltic Sea their
investment partner is a surprising
newcomer to the alternative energy
industry Norwegian oil and gas giant
stat oil
altogether is 1.2 billion euros and
we're taking 50% of that we're talking
real money here it's not just branding
or greenwashing
we expect tremendous growth with in
particular and you know if you're a
business person you want to take
advantage of those growth opportunities
and be part of it
statoil like Eon is positioning itself
to take advantage of the energy
industries new horizons the company's
next project draws on four decades of
offshore experience to steal a march on
far new arrivals always exciting it's
the first floating full-scale windmill
in the world the image is very windy it
looks like it still but it's actually
floating the world's biggest offshore
operator has developed a floating
turbine there can be mass-produced
cheaper and quicker than existing static
windmills
I think it actually makes some sense
that it was an oil and gas company that
came up with this because we are reusing
a lot of technology on the oil and gas
sector we're using that phone technology
it's ballasted it doesn't have any legs
the special software allows the blades
to move in certain direction which
optimizes the wind production but it
also makes the power stand still
start oils first floating windfarm a
sheduled to be delivered to a site off
the east coast of Scotland by 2017
I think this is the future it's a future
wind at least you can have them anywhere
in the world anywhere in any kind of sea
so this allows us to move further from
shore get better wind and produce
cheaper electricity other fossil fuel
giants including Shell Exxon and total
are also starting to hedge their bets
with a range of investments in biofuel
batteries solar and wind it might seem
like a surprising move but by embracing
these alternative technologies now
forward-thinking oil and gas companies
might just be able to withstand the
disruption caused by the Renewable
Revolution
you